>>> I AM BECKY ANDERSON.
IT IS 10:00 A.M.
IN NEW YORK.
IT IS 3:00 P.M.
HERE IN LONDON.
THE ALARM BELLS ARE DEAFENING.
THE UNITED NATIONS ISSUING AN
URGENT CALL FOR ACTION IN ITS
MOST COMPREHENSIVE LOOK YET AT
OUR GLOBAL CLIMATE CRISIS.
YEARS IN THE MAKING REPORTS
HUMAN CREATED GREENHOUSE GASES
ARE UNDENIABLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
GLOBAL WARMING.
THE REPORT WARNS THE ONLY WAY
TO STOP AND REVERSE WARMING IS
TO CUT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
TO ZERO.
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACT ALREADY
SEVERE IN EVERY REGION OF THE
PLANET.
IT WOULD GET WORSE WITH EVERY
FRACTION OF A DEGREE OF WARMING.
CONNECTING US TODAY FROM NEW
YORK.
IT WASN'T LIKE WE HAVEN'T BEEN
WARNED.
WHAT IS NEW AND DIFFERENT ABOUT
THIS REPORT?
>> IT IS A CERTAINTY.
THE HUGE DATA SETS AND BETTER
SATELLITES THAT PROVE NOT ONLY
PREDICTIONS OF 30 YEARS AGO BUT
REAFFIRMS THOSE PREDICTIONS
WERE CONSERVATIVE.
IT IS HAPPENING FASTER AND MORE
DRAMATICALLY THAN ANYONE EVER
PREDICT.
THEY MOVED UP ABOUT A DECADE TO
WHEN WE MIGHT PASS THE RED LINE
IN THE SAND THAT WOULD HAPPEN
IN THE EARLY 30s AND LAND
BETWEEN THREE AND FIVE DEGREES
OF WARMING CELSIUS PAST
PREINDUSTRIAL LEVELS WHICH IS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PLANET ON
SO MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS.
IT IS DIRECTLY DETERMINED FOR
WHAT IS BEING DONE RIGHT NOW.
THEY STARTED BUILDING POLITICAL
WILL INTO THE MODELS.
A GREEN PATH WHERE COUNTRIES
WORK TOGETHER, THIS IS WHERE WE
ARE HEADED.
ULTIMATELY IS THE BIGGEST X
FACTOR OF HUMAN NATURE.
>> WE'RE LOOKING AT IMAGES OF
YOU IN GREENLAND.
TELL US WHAT YOU WITNESSED
THERE.>> THEY ARE SORT OF ON
THE DEFRAUD SETTING OF PLANET
EARTH.
LIFE IS EASIER AND IT'S EASIER
TO FISH FOR A LIVING.
IT'S NOT ONLY RISKING THE LIVES
BUT IT IS SHUTTING SO MUCH
FRESHWATER IT COULD STOP THE
OCEAN CURRENTS OF THE
GULFSTREAM.
ONE DAY LAST WEEK ANOTHER
GREENLAND MELTED TO COVER THE
STATE OF FLORIDA IN TWO INCHES
OF WATER.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING WHEN WE
ARE NOT PAYING ATTENTION.
WHEN WE ARE FOCUSED ON
WILDFIRES.
SEA LEVEL RISE IS A BIG PART OF
THIS REPORT THINK IT COULD BE
TWO METERS OR 22 METERS.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF HOW SOON
HUMANITY CHANGES ITS FUELS.?
IF WE HAVE CAUSED IT, HOW ABOUT
SOME SOLUTIONS AT LEAST IN THE
SHORT TERM?>> THE THING TO
FOCUS ON IMMEDIATELY IS
METHANE.
IT LAYS BARE THAT THE THEORY
THAT THIS IS A CLEANER BRIDGE
FUEL IF YOU IMAGINE A BABY IN
THE CAR ON A HOT DAY, THAT IS
CARBON DIOXIDE TRAPPING THE
HEAT.
IT ACTS MUCH FASTER AND IS
EASIER TO CONTROL.
BY CAPPING DAIRY FARMS AND
FIGURING OUT HOW TO CAPTURE ALL
OF THAT POLLUTION THAT IS
LEAKING UNCHECKED FROM
OILFIELDS, THAT WOULD BE THE
FIRST PLACE TO START.
WE HAVE TO DO THAT TO SUCCEED.
LET'S START THERE.
THERE IS A CONVERSATION NOW
THAT COULD BE MADE HOW MUCH IT
WILL COST IF WE DO NOTHING.>>
YOU AND I WILL TALK REGULARLY
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT GOING AWAY.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT WE CAN ALL
DEAL TO GET ON WITH THIS.
WE GET IT AND WE KNOW YOU GET
IT, FOLKS.
LOOK AT GREECE BEING RAVAGED BY
WILDFIRES.
NATIONS ACROSS THE WORLD HAVE
STEPPED UP SENDING HELP.
MAKING IT WORSE, DANGEROUS
CLIMATE CONDITIONS.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO THE ISLAND.
FIRES THERE ARE BURNING OUT OF
CONTROL.
WHAT ARE YOU WITNESSING?>>
THERE ARE FOUR FRONTS RIGHT
NOW.
WE ARE BASICALLY VERY CLOSE TO
WHERE THE FIRES ARE CURRENTLY
BLAZING.
LOOKING BEHIND ME HERE, THIS IS
THE APOCALYPTIC SCENARIO.
THE AFTERMATH OF THE BLAZE THAT
HAS RIPPED THROUGH SO MANY
PARTS OF THIS ISLAND.
450,000 OF PRECIOUS FOREST HAVE
BEEN COMPLETELY DESTROYED.
FROM BEGINNING OF THE HEAT WAVE
GIVES YOU A SENSE OF THE SCALE.
THE FIREFIGHTERS, THEY SAY
THEY'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING AT
THIS SCALE IN THE PAST.
NEVER THIS INTENSE AND
AGGRESSIVE.
THE COMPOUNDING ISSUE IS THE
HEAT WAVE THAT HAS RIPPED
THROUGH THE COUNTRY FOR THE
PAST FEW DAYS AND THAT OF
COURSE INTENSIFIES THE IMPACT
OF THE FIRE.
YOU CAN SEE HERE YOU GOT
ELECTRICITY POLES THAT HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT A VERY STARK
SCENARIO.
PEOPLE BEING EVACUATED AND WE
FOUND VILLAGES THAT WERE ABOUT
ONE KILOMETER AWAY FROM THE
BLAZING FIRE THAT DECIDED TO
STAY TO PROTECT THEIR
LIVELIHOOD.
IT WAS SO FASCINATING TO SEE
MEN AND WOMEN TRYING TO GET
WATER TO FIREFIGHTERS THIS IS
THE SEVENTH DAY.
IT IS UNPRECEDENTED AND PEOPLE
ARE SHOCKED AND DISTRAUGHT AT
THE DESTRUCTION.
? THAT IS THE STORY IN GREECE
AT PRESENT.
CALIFORNIA ALSO LIVING WITH THE
IMPACT OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS
RIGHT NOW.
THE MASSIVE DIXIE FIRE.
THE SECOND LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
STATE HISTORY AND IT IS STILL
GROWING.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE UNDER
EVACUATION ORDERS.
THIS FIRE ISN'T JUST AFFECTING
THOSE WHO LIVE IN ITS PATH.
SMOKE FROM THE BLAZE IS
BLANKETING COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE REGION.
CAMILLA IS IN PARADISE
CALIFORNIA WITH MORE.
>> THE SMOKE IS THICK AND
UNHEALTHY.
IF YOU LOOK IT BEHIND ME, YOU
ARE NORMALLY SUPPOSED TO SEE A
CANYON.
INSTEAD YOU ARE SEEING IT
FILLED WITH SMOKE.
THE SMOKE COMING SOUTH FROM THE
DIXIE FIRE AND IS NOT ONLY
FLOODING THIS CANYON BUT ALSO
THE COMMUNITIES NEARBY.
THE FIRE HAS BEEN BURNING FOR
ALMOST A MONTH.
WE ARE SEEING A GROWING BUT WE
ARE NOT SEEING MUCH PROGRESS ON
CONTAINMENT.
WE ARE SEEING THE NUMBER OF
STRUCTURES DESTROYED.
IT'S NOW ABOUT 400 STRUCTURES
BEING DESTROYED BY THIS FIRE.
SEEMINGLY EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS AND DROUGHT LEADING
TO EXTREME CONDITIONS AND
WILDFIRE CHALLENGES LIKE WHAT
WE'VE NEVER SEEN IN OUR
HISTORY.
AS A CONSEQUENCE, WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THESE ARE CLIMATE
INDUCED WILDFIRES AND WE HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE, WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY IN THIS COUNTRY TO
SOLVE THIS.
>> GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM DID
POINT TO PREVENTION LIKE
MANAGING THE FOREST BUT MADE IT
CLEAR THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
HE ALSO THANKED THE 8500 MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE WORKING TO
STOP THIS FIRE.
>> MORE THAN 500 PEOPLE THERE
BATTLING A WILDFIRE.
FIREFIGHTERS, SOLDIERS AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS ARE PITCHING IN
TO BATTLE THESE FLAMES.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO REPORTS OF
INJURIES OR DEATHS THANKFULLY
THERE.
EXTREME WEATHE